I came at a bad time
Listen to the fireworks Listen to Konohamaru-chan's story Yume
me
2 minutes
If something happens to me, I'm worried and worried
[music]
Ice is really a
naive child Is it okay if you meet me, sister, sister?
Well,
I'd be happier to be called
Konohamaru's older brother This is the older brother of Arcap If it turns out to be Boruto as it is, then this is
the first withdrawal made by my older brother.
It's just Kahoko who said that we don't want to receive income sources
.
This time when I'm sober, even the teacher is on our side.
It was delicious that there was no alcohol In
order to control most of the
masters
[music] It's an
ogre  I told
you to talk about the chunin exams
.